i want to talk about cultural decay
and uh we have this story here from the
daily mail
women hikers throw the kitchen sinks at
gender stereotypes as they climb
scaffold pike with washing stations
attached to their backs in fight for
equality wow congratulations to emma
woodhall april wilson and xena clark for
carrying
kitchen sinks
on top of a mountain uh okay i just i
have so much to say about this for one i
hope everybody's laughing a lot right
now looking at this image of women with
sinks strapped to their backs
i honestly think this reinforces the
gender stereotype
it's like
you went hiking but instead of just
hiking you have brought a sink with you
reinforcing that you are to be around it
that's a terrible idea
i really respect it you know it's been
difficult for me to figure out how to do
shows like this when i have to stay in
my kitchen as you know i also under the
table have a kitchen sink oh right did
you finish the dishes yet so this is
like a really
working on it but so so here's your feet
here's what i see here there's there's
there's a couple big things in this
story one
people are insane
right no and i mean like i mean that in
kind of a colloquial sense like
there's no logic behind this it's a
stunt they're trying to get attention
they got it the media wrote about it hey
that's a good workout too yeah that's
great it's a good workout it's like a
farmer's walk up a mountain that's true
that's true well that's a fair that's
that's a good that's a positive right
my point is negative why would someone
do something so absurd
clicks instagram likes they're trying
they're peacocking they're trying to
flutter their feathers back notice me
they're doing nothing to actually target
patriarchy or whatever they think is
going on they're making no cultural
change no political change
this is the perfect example in my
opinion of the narcissistic vapid youth
i should say youth i mean these people
are 40. but like 40 yeah this generation
that doesn't understand the problem
doesn't have a solution but stands on
top of a pedestal holding a kitchen sink
so that people notice them and they can
claim they're doing something this
exemplifies all of it listen you don't
you don't know what it's like to be so
attention starved
dying here
they're going to be hospitalized in two
weeks if they don't get more clicks what
is the purpose of their movement here
what were they doing protesting
patriarchy is that the vague yes yeah
that's the i think
numbers gender stereotypes protesting
gender stereotypes by reinforcing them
with a kitchen sink they're worth more
than this i feel like they should have
carried porcelain sinks yeah so pretty
long heavier yeah it's been it's been
52 years
right since the since the start of
i guess the gender equality stuff 70 was
around the time we started seeing more
women enter the workforce
52 years
but no matter how much they win and they
are winning they're more likely to go to
college less likely to be homeless
millennial women and younger make more
money than millennial men they're still
acting like they're the oppressed
victims well to an extent i do think
people hate women now more than ever but
it's their fault
i would say you know when i was growing
up when we would like banter back and
forth like even when i played a bit of
video games when i grew up the jokes
were always like go make me a sandwich
or something now they're like go die in
a whole you like slur like people i i
think the gender dynamics have become so
just escalated because there's so much
tension and hatred because we've been so
pitched against each other where it's
like oh i didn't get that job because a
woman just got that position because she
was a woman she got to become the
fighter pilot in the military she got
the professor position she got the
scholarship whatever it is and now
instead of just seeing women as humans
because feminism was like okay we're
equal now men see them as this like
force that's trying to dominate them and
it's become really sinister it's quite
sad it's quite sad to see us pitched
against each other so much
i suspect that feminism is a lot like so
i don't really care for unions anymore
because they've served their purpose and
now they're done i think that feminism
is exactly the same they accomplished
what they set out to and we had richie
mcginnis mom on the show and she was
talking about the stuff that the
legitimate struggles that they actually
had to get women to have equal rights to
men and for the ability to work that's
great that's fine we have all that now
we're done we don't need feminists
anymore i really don't think we do and
we're doing stuff like strapping sinks
to our backs lightweight sinks for the
record so it's not like they're doing
any kind of military drill they're
lightweight yeah well they're like
they're like porcelain yeah they're
metal aluminum i've carried things like
that before so they're like aluminum
yeah yeah and it's it's not
disappointing actually it's just they
didn't commit to it yeah they really
didn't yeah probably honestly the back
of their legs while they're walking yeah
no feminism completely unnecessary well
disappointed they wore shoes i do
believe we're intellectual equals men
and women which is important to to
maintain like what is that what does
that mean that we're both capable of
doing math problems eq like no no man or
woman coming out of the womb is going to
be better or worse because of their
gender in intellectual competition men
on average are going to be better at
things like maths but i do think that
it's obviously there are women that can
meet and rise to that level um and i
also think it's really taken for granted
uh different types of intelligence like
eq emotional intelligence i do think
women tend to have higher emotional
intelligence than men what does that
mean though um
like ability to read people process
emotions and social situations um and
these things are studied quite
extensively so it's important to see
averages and differences but then judge
people as individuals yeah ian there's
something called the greater male
variability hypothesis which shows that
males are more likely to be extremely
stupid but more likely to be extremely
smart so when you look at the highest
and lowest end of the bell curve for
male talent be it math be it basketball
they they so here's the here's the issue
when it comes to the fortune 500s
of the however many companies that exist
in the world
500 get that top slot the fortune 500
the biggest the best
so when you have when you have 100 men
and 100 women
and
on the female bell curve
five percent of women are really dumb
ten percent are below average and then
you've got uh what seventy percent
average then fifteen slightly above
average and five percent
my math is weird but i know what you
mean yeah ten percent ten percent twenty
thirty right seventy in the middle yeah
so the issue for men is that you're
going to have 50 in the middle
way more dumb people
but way more smart people
so if you have
uh out of 100 guys
10 in the highest end of the bell curve
and then out of the women five in the
highest end of the bell curve and even
then the highest high point is male
now do a top ten ranking in a ability to
run a business and guess what's gonna
happen you're gonna have nine dudes in
one chick or not even that there are 10
guys
and all have been competing against them
all the women may lose that's not
anomalous you only got 15 people
competing in all likelihood the top
eight slots will be men and then two
will be women and people say how does
that make sense there's 50 men you know
50 100 men and 100 women should be equal
shouldn't it no
because you will also have substantially
more really really dumb men this is why
i think so many women think guys are
dumb because there's a whole lot of
really dumb guys relative to women
equals not is a very vague term in that
it doesn't mean the same doesn't mean
we're the same and and i think in the
past the extremes have dictated the the
generalizations like okay eight out of
ten ceos are men therefore men make
better ceos but that's not
you know across the board i think you
need to make space for the women who are
good at that because i do
there are women that are not going to be
the norm they're not going to want to be
mothers they're going to want to pursue
careers they're going to find that
really really fulfilling and you need to
make space for that and as long as
there's space for that you're fine what
we're doing now unfortunately though is
we're trying to force women into a
larger space than they even need well i
i would put it this way
luxuries eventually become necessities
so cell phones for instance when cell
phones first came out it was a novelty
seeing the guy with that really big
phone and it's like if i'm in this one
block radius i can call my work then you
got car phones and all of a sudden now
is a luxury you had the opportunity to
make a call from your vehicle most
people still operated under you call me
when i'm at the office or at home
when cell phones became ubiquitous all
of a sudden now you got two workers
one with a cell phone one without who's
getting hired oh dude with a cell phone
hands down i can call you at any time i
can i can get answers to questions hire
the person with a cell phone that luxury
became a necessity and now you're not
going to get hired if you don't have one
women entering the workforce it started
out as women who want to work can work
no one's saying they shouldn't you know
we're changing things
and then once women started entering the
workforce
you now had dual income households
competing against single income
households and this so all of a sudden
you have a business that says listen
we've got a dual income household they
can take the job for 30 000 a year you
know because the husband and wife are
both working sorry i know you have a
family but you need too much money i'm
going to hire the the woman now you've
got double the workforce overnight
without a doubling of the work uh supply
and then you see
suppression of wages you see collapse
and eventually then you come to a point
where women have to work it started out
as they can if they want to and now it's
better otherwise you're broke because no
one can afford it yeah i was thinking
about what you said about emotional
quotient eq and iq being different like
i'll have a conversation with when my
girlfriend's involved in conversations
like sometimes tim and i'll get into it
and it'll be like it'll get heightened
and it'll get fast and loud and she's
like i don't want to be around the tone
and i'm like what i'm not even thinking
about the tone i'm thinking about what
we're saying sort of the man to our
brains it's like the information is is
more important but to her it's like it's
the
feeling of the situation is altering the
way you're producing the information
and this is the big myth that
conservatives often struggle with we do
the facts don't care about your feelings
feelings are more important than facts
feelings are way more important feelings
don't care about your facts yeah
absolutely and we need to take that into
account we need what makes people
motivated to do anything is how they
feel anything political the only reason
they care about the facts is because i
love my family and i want to protect my
family so i'm going to go look into the
facts to see what the best ways are to
do that i mean let's be real if if uh
if your kid someone if your child did
something illegal i think most people
would be like i have to protect my son
at all costs yep yeah like they will
they know it's wrong they know it's
against the law don't care my kid's not
going to jail but that's one of the
problems with conservatives we go to the
head first not the heart yes yeah you
got to figure that i think it's
fascinating ben shapiro's tweet while i
respect it you know facts don't care
about your feelings get like a hundred
thousand retweets it goes viral like
crazy when i saw that i was just like
yeah but feelings don't care about your
facts right and i think that's
substantially more important to the
conversation i'll be it's wrong
but the issue is if you go to someone
and tell them like i don't know michael
brown didn't have his hands up obama's
doj came out and said that was not true
they'll just get angry because your
facts are meaningless to how they feel
about it but this is one of the
actual principles of the less organizing
appeal to the heart first to put the
hands and feet into motion yeah they
figured it out like again
appeal to the heart get people into
motion sometimes the facts line up
sometimes they don't but it doesn't
matter you've got people motivated in
the right direction to do what you want
them to do i keep thinking about god
like the emotions attached to really
believing in that that
and like that that's similar to what
people in occult will do like and i'm
talking about people that are like in
the media cult whatever you are called
on the left or whatever like it's so
emotionally driven because they truly
believe in it and i know that emotion is
there in people on all sides
the the issue is they they they may not
believe in it and their brain doesn't
let them ever even consider it they feel
physical pain it's like what brandon
strzok told us that when he was first
breaking out of the left and he saw the
video of trump doing the arm thing it
was physically painful to be proven
wrong so there are a lot of people they
don't they don't actually believe it
when you present them with facts and
hand them the sheet showing it they get
really angry because they know deep down
their brain is telling them this
is true but we cannot accept it we
cannot a lot of them have personal
trauma connected to their politics as
most people do you know you look with
feminists and this is something i wish i
acknowledged more when i was younger and
kind of challenging the feminist
movement is they they had bad
relationships with their father a
horrible abusive relationship or
whatever and they're projecting that
personal experience onto the broader
political discourse because it's easier
to deal with something that's far away
from you
than to really like look inward at your
own personal pain so they'll try to
fight it through these larger political
battles it's the same with trump trump
is just the representation of their
christian parents that were distant and
at work all the time and not talking to
them and they hate it and they're
rejecting and rebelling against it and a
lot of people had those personal
experiences with their family where they
grew up in a you know christian
conservative household that they're
fighting back against they had a bad
experience with a man or whatever it
might be and and that's their emotional
place they're in and i think we do as
much as they do really stupid stuff and
really wreck our society we do need to
see the left as humans that are just you
know very confused in a lot of ways and
we do need to reach out to them on an
emotional level and try to pull them
back from that edge i know uh we don't
like humanizing the left but we have to
therefore i don't disagree i just don't
know where you find the middle ground
with them no i don't think i've seen you
no you need to feel it if you cry openly
out of joy out of belief not out of
sadness or pain but like out of truly
believing it people resonate the middle
ground is not in arguments and political
discussions because feelings don't care
about facts the middle ground is in
we uh i brought this up several days now
but we're launching shows at timcast.com
i think right now it's like 80 of the
content we produce is not political okay
the overwhelming majority of it is not
political at all because i don't want to
go to somebody who is only peripherally
involved in politics and very angry and
start yelling politics at them i want
them to be like hey man i don't know
about all that stuff why don't you come
hang out we'll tell a ghost story we'll
sit around the campfire we'll have
marshmallows that is so much more
attractive to many people now
politics has become pop culture the view
talking about turning point usa there
are people who are turning on tv for
entertainment and then being bludgeoned
over the head with ideology
my attitude is this twofold one let's
just hang out have a good time have
pizza not talk about that stuff put
these people in an environment where
they're away from that and something
interesting happens when they're
dedicating their time to watching
sitcoms or or um like you know we've
talked from the inverted world and we're
launching a bunch of other shows
they're not they're not in a world of
pain anymore
now they're going to look back and
they're going to see people screaming
but trump but trump i'm going to go that
made me feel miserable can i just listen
to the ghost stories because right now
i'm just interested we got to give them
a space that is just not overly
political but the other thing is
when we create cool fun stuff and we're
doing back flips into foam pits then
we're all all over here cheering and
high-fiving each other and being like
come on come party and hang out we're
doing back flips sounds fun it's a
bouncy castle coming out we don't want
to talk about that painful stuff it's an
escape i think that's what we got to do
to help people break away from the cult
yeah so many conservatives have just
portrayed themselves as we sit and we
read books all day and pray all day you
know praying right you should do it but
you're we're humans too
we're scared to show that but is the
thing about like turning point usa is
like i think they do great work but
they're all suits
you know like cpac tp usa these big
events and i'm like
grow your hair out
you know look man you're not you're
you're connected you're nervous there's
a certain kind of person
that
you know uh believe i i idealizes facts
don't care about your feelings
it's it's correct you know facts matter
more than how you feel about them in my
opinion but politically feelings matter
more to the average person so my
attitude is just like where is the space
for people who are sick and tired of the
woke cult who just want to watch some
guy do a backflip escapism
just relax you know escapism here's what
happened i'll tell you this we're making
we're working on a video game we showed
you guys the the video game earlier
today
we're working on a video game out here
and it's because i'm like
people want to play a video game and
what happens all of a sudden it's
wokeness they make battlefield or what
was it called was it battlefield
battlefield where the woman had like
purple hair and a and like a prosthetic
or something and everyone's like what
what is going on
every movie's got to be some political
message every show has got to be
political as much as i'm a fan of the
show the boys it's just come on stop
hitting me over the head with this stuff
does every show have to be like this
resident evil it's like come on yeah i
don't even think oh are you gonna say i
was just i don't think it's escapism
when people want to like i like
off-roading i like going out shooting
swimming every other day i don't think
any of that's escapism i think that's
how humans are supposed to live um life
is lived in the in between we're not
supposed to be thinking about politics
every second we're supposed to be
actually spending time with friends
family and it's okay for people who are
political personalities to go out and
show that side of themselves to say
actually
this is what's important to me and this
is how i want you to be living that's
why i care about politics so you don't
have to worry about the government
infringing on your ability to do these
things and actually live your life with
your families so we have to care about
politics but it's not what we're
supposed to be doing 24 7. agreed i
think about like the universe and
consciousness and like sometimes people
like oh he's a psychedelic tripster
think you know wasting yeah get out of
here but like it's self-preservation and
the preservation of our species because
every 20 000 years this planet gets hit
by comets you know or however 40
thousand years everything's reset
everybody's wiped out so we need to get
off this planet if we want to keep
having conversations about politics and
that's i'm a big advocate of
communicating about politics about
social structure but we have got to
focus on science you create a space
where like you know timcast has a news
outlet as well right but we we we've
been investing heavily in tales from the
inverted world and i will just tell
everybody for those that are interested
in knowing the the click-through rates
the the cost per click all that stuff
has been ridiculous like so we're doing
ads this is uh shane cashman he went
down to georgia investigating lost
confederate gold it is only political in
that sense of the history but for the
most part it's just his journey meaning
witches ufos someone threaten to kill
him because he's trying to find this
gold it is just outside of the realm of
modern political culture war stuff and
the the click-through rate is like
double or triple what we see in other
ads we've only recently started doing ad
stuff and i'm like this is good news
regular people
when you go on facebook you see them
inundated with memes about politics
anger and hatred and it's like let's
let's promote this
and pull them out of that space and then
allow that kind of hatred to evaporate
for a little bit but here's the best
part timcast.com has a news section with
true facts
so if they're doing nothing but watching
msnbc and getting wrapped into it we
pull them out and offer them a space to
just relax and watch ghost stories or
sitcoms or chicken city and then if they
end up seeing the news the news is
neutral straightforward and fact-driven
what do you do when you're not involved
thinking about politics what are your
main focuses
hunting oh what kind of stuff what's
your hunting style like uh deer i'll do
everything crossbow muzzleloader
crossbow we got deer out here like crazy
every night when i go back down there's
a bunch of deer in my lawn
brother-in-law and i actually my son uh
we hunt we'll do we'll do the
knock them down in the woods field dress
them
bring them in we process them in the
barn
what do you what do you so when you get
a deer like do you you make a bunch of
different kinds of meat you make like
jerky salami i usually my brother-in-law
awesome he
literally will process
almost everything on the deer either you
know give the ribs to the dogs and you
eat the marrow i don't i mean like do
people like we'll take the deer marrow
maybe boil it make it yeah
i don't i literally take the back strap
i take the inner tenderloins i take the
rumps and i typically make those into
either a stew or i'll do biltong
or i'll do jerky
that's deer tenderloin it's a south
african
form of jerky
it's really good deer tenderloin is that
similar in any way to like standard cow
or um i mean it's the the inner
tenderloin is the best part of a deer
and
i soak it in whiskey garlic salt and
pepper overnight
i beat it out
and then i fry it with some fresh eggs
from our chickens that sounds amazing
and you do it right it's superb i had a
friend who brought me to this dude's
house once and he they did a full
process they had every kind of like meat
you could make from a deer i was like
we've been on planner we have done my my
brother-in-law
was like we've got to do some sausage so
we did you know half of it is
sausage half as venison and then we did
jalapeno and we did cheddar
amazing
stuffed you stopped yeah we stuffed our
own sausage you know he comes through
the intestines yeah i like your answer
to his question you're like trying to
find what's your like non-political
chill thing you're like oh yeah when i'm
not destroying leftists i'm i'm shooting
i'm killing things in the woods
what about turkeys
turkeys are terrible yeah have you ever
eaten any wild turkeys nope they're
awful yeah yeah wild what's what's bad
about it well they're extremely lean
meats
and i i probably screwed up on how i
prepared it i probably i've heard people
that you just gotta slow cook it like
crazy to get it to where it's edible
um what else do i do that when i'm not
shooting things or destroying leftists
i'm i'm actually big into horticulture
i've got my orchards i've got orchards
what are you growing peaches apples
cherries um got raised with a raised bed
with blueberries what percentage of your
uh diet would you say comes from your
own production
not enough
i mean i want to get to the point where
i don't know during deer season no not
half
we've got the eggs we've got some
venison the only problem is there's not
many people in the household that love
venison so it's like
yeah well you eat what you eat you know
what i mean we brought you a deer back
time to eat it yeah we do i mean the
part of the other raised bed is like a
jalapeno uh tomato poblano peppers we're
doing salsa garden okay you got to stop
describing food i'm about to no it's
amazing
we do have fun i do other things outside
of politics and it's actually i mean it
it does actually
like you get away from it and and you
become a full you i fully realize you
know all aspects of your humanness i
think people should uh people listening
especially now should start figuring out
how to
um
create a larger percentage of their own
uh i totally agree yeah no this is one
of the things i'm trying to figure we've
got
30 some acres
20 of it's 21 of us for us and we're
trying to figure out how can i make the
other 10 acres or so productive yeah and
what can i do with those we've got too
many eggs here because we now have like
30 chickens and the new ones are
starting to lay my wife is a chicken
lady we are going to have like
25 eggs per day what do you do with them
when you have so many we're giving them
to people oh yeah we have the same
situation we we've had a raccoon fox
situation so we don't have that many
eggs these days wait a minute
but that was taken care of what's more
dangerous the fox of the raccoon
uh
so here's how it works the raccoons just
pick them off one by one usually they
just murder them right they don't even
need them they suck the blood out of
them they're literally vampires yeah the
foxes will come in and it's a massacre
in like 10 minutes oh cause they're fun
they're just killing him killing kill
and killing him they'll drag a couple
off eat them but there's just you i went
down one time it was probably three or 3
30 in the afternoon everybody was fine
had to go back up to the house the barns
maybe i don't know 100 yards below the
house went up back to the house did some
stuff came back i'm not kidding 30 40
minutes later
like 15 of them were dead wow the fox
had just come and nailed them all
i don't think i was able to kill that
one have you ever shot the foxes that
come i have yeah the the
one of them got away partly because the
neighbors have horses and it was not a
clear shot so i held back which is the
right thing to do but the other one i
shot and then um
there'd been some raccoons shooting your
neighbor's horse yeah no that's that
would be funny yeah no raccoons you know
raccoons
two barrels of a 12 gauge takes care of
them we got it we got a raccoon problem
we set up a trap we uh we took care of
one of them yeah the the so i mean we
have a so this is what's what's worrying
is that we have uh uh we have dogs
and they're still coming around which
they shouldn't be because
our open area right now the chickens is
not particularly large but
i saw fox so we have a cat his name is
bucko
and i'm recording one day this is a
couple months ago and he's sitting
in the middle in the field and from from
my studio i can see the whole backyard i
can see the chickens like really wide
view and i see him sitting to the middle
of the field in a loaf like cats do when
a very gaunt looking fox starts creeping
out of the brush and slowly moving
towards him and my cat being dumb just
stood there staring and then i was like
i'm in the middle of recording a segment
20 like 15 minutes in like so that's
nearly done for my morning segment and i
had no i i stopped i got up and i ran
outside and started yelling and the fox
did not run and i did you know jump over
the fence or jump over the railing and
like run down and the fox took off uh
i'm worried the fox was starving that's
why i was coming onto the property
fearless of the dog and going after my
cat and my cat's too stupid to run away
from it just saying that cat was going
to rush and that's face up no that fox
right and then when the fox ran off cat
just looks at me and then just looks
back at the woods and just doesn't even
blink do you have kaya wolves out here i
don't know we have coyotes well so
there's
there's been a crossbreed that's
developed between wolves and coyotes
they're called kaya wolves
we have modern property i haven't heard
them recently what do they like they
look like small wolves wow they don't
look i mean we had ton i grew up in
kansas we had a ton of coyotes
very like obvious coyotes these coyote
wolves look like small wolves are they
vicious like like wolves yeah i mean
they're pretty aggressive i'll go
through the forest i haven't seen
anything recently but you'll go through
and it's it's literally like a pack of
them hit a deer and there's parts
everywhere i've been thinking lately are
raccoons a kind of animal that we would
be better off wiping out like making
extinct or do they do any value to the
system trash pandas they're kind of cute
no have you guys ever seen that video of
the uh guy's dog being attacked by a
raccoon and he's like above a stairwell
and he grabs the raccoon and just like
flips it around and throws it down the
stairs and all you see are these little
glowing eyes disappearing into the abyss
no no okay it's a great video you gotta
find that one thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you